huggy rao is the atoll mcbean professor
of organizational behavior and human
resources
graduate school of business and
professor by courtesy of sociology at
stanford university
his most recent book co-authored with
bob sutton
is scaling up excellence which is a wall
street journal bestseller and was
included in the best business books to
read in 2014 by
financial times inc magazine amazon
forbes
washington post and the library journal
just basically everywhere
his research has been published in
numerous scientific journals and he has
served as the editor of administrative
science
quarterly and has been a member of the
editorial boards of american journal of
sociology
and organization science and academy of
management review
now you guys have heard me introduce
huggy before i could go on and on with
all the
numbers and the acronyms behind his name
but he's just a really
awesome person and guy and i'm so glad
that you're here with us today huggy
it's always a pleasure and with that
thank you so very much
robin for that gracious and very
thank you so much for your gracious and
generous introduction robin
i'm so glad you teed up scaling up
excellence i should add
that my wonderful co-author collaborator
and john's and mine's collective friend
bob sutton
he's also on the webinar as a listener
so he tells me
today we're very very fortunate to have
john lilly visitors now how do i
describe
john lilly uh put simply
uh john is you know
one of the most interesting people i've
really met in the
valley john is a computer science
undergrad and a master's in computer
science
from stanford university then founded
his own company reactivity
was the ceo who led mozilla particularly
the introduction and implementation of
firefox
subsequently after that he served as a
partner in greylock
ventures for several years and today he
advised the ceos and the lied
but most of all i'm personally very
grateful to john
because john actually sets aside some
time
to teach a class on building company
culture
from startup to scale up at the stanford
business school
along with another compadre suje
jaswa the three of us come to class
and what we do is we challenge students
and we all disagree and the students
have a lot of fun
but the amazing thing about john is john
on the one hand is very attentive to
research
and at the same time very very informed
about ground ground-level realities so
he is able to marry
both clean models and dirty hands
we're very thankful to you john welcome
thanks again it's good to see you thank
you
so to our listeners we're very grateful
to all of you for having set aside
time as robin telegraphed i want to make
this a conversation
and the way we'll make it a conversation
is i'll tea up a few questions with john
so and then after that i'd very much
encourage you to use the chat option
to write out your questions and then
we'll actually
uh you know respond to those questions
as well
just so that all of you are emphatically
clear
both john and i treat questions as gifts
not as interruptions so please please
use the chat option
the more questions the better and we'll
respond to them
um you know as soon as
robin triages them for us in meaningful
chance
wonderful so john let's actually begin
our conversation
what is company culture you know you've
been a vc you've been a ceo
you know when you walk into a startup
how do you sense its culture
like things telegraph you that this is
culture
sure yeah i think culture's
misunderstood i think most people it's a
pretty squishy term i think most people
don't totally understand what it means
um i think of it in two different ways i
think of it one one of the definitions i
think about it is it's the way you make
decisions
especially when the leaders or the
founders aren't in the room
so it's the way that things really
happen in an organization that's one of
the things
another way i say it sometimes is that
it's the company values
realized or operationalized so it's it's
the
values in action and that actually leads
you to this other thing which is that
it tends to be this this reinforcing
cycle so
you'll tend to have values that are
intentional and
or there is some degree of intentional
those will affect how you build the
cultural
norms in your company and those cultural
norms will either
reinforce the values or undermine the
values this time of this
this virtuous or vicious cycle uh but
it's a lot around intentionality and so
you know i think a lot of people like to
say like
if uh you know you build your culture or
it builds you at some level so
that's something i think about it's like
how how you do things how you make
decisions
and that's the the real the reality of
your values
i love the way you've just described it
you build culture
culture builds you can you just expand
on that just a little bit please
what does building culture mean john and
how does culture build you or me if we
are members
of the same organization sure yeah like
the um
you know uh one like people
no one will say everyone will tell you
they don't like politics and
organizations for example
and so you might have a value that well
we're a politic
free organization which is basically an
oxymoron there's no politics free
organizations but
to the degree that you uh believe in
transparency and that kind of stuff
that that you might say you believe and
there's no politics but then to the
degree that you let politics enter into
decision making you know you'll see that
start to
grow because people are quite smart
about how to how things
actually happen how to get things done
and then that will tend to erode the
build
erode the belief that what you say your
values are actually your values and so
it's you know it's it's just one simple
example but
the the way you do things will tend to
either reinforce
what you say you are or undermine it and
everyone is
i think smart enough to see that
everyone is smart enough to see that
so often um not just in the valley but
everywhere
people talk about culture eats strategy
for breakfast
what do people mean by that what's your
take and if i'm a founder
when do i think of culture after
deciding my strategy
after designing my the beta version of
my product when do i begin to think of
culture
yeah this is another this is another
motto that i think um takes some
explaining because i i think that
it's um it's a little bit uh people rely
on it too much and they say well
this is why we have a super nice culture
a super kind culture
and i think what you're really saying is
that what what i
what i take away from it when you say
culturally strategy for breakfast is
if you build the right kind of company
that tends to grow the right
kind of people and leaders in all levels
whether it's
just leaders at the leaf level or
leaders in the management level
then you will tend to get reinforcing
and strong
action in in the right ways now but
that means each of them will be able to
uh
operate against the strategy but you
can't i mean you can't have culture
without a strategy you can't have
strategy without a culture you need you
need both things to operate in concert
but what you're really trying to figure
out is like how do i create an
organization
that can operate against the strategy
itself and how and
create strategies a good time so if i
can create an organization with
leadership
who understands why we're doing what
we're doing and can make changes
and can change strategy and tactics over
time obviously that's better than having
one single source of strategy all the
time and so
you're really talking about culture to
develop people and leaders
and decision making capabilities
that that's what they can execute in a
strategy that's executing strategy
now you know allow me to please take you
to mozilla
you're the new ceo there you've just
taken over the company
how did you go about addressing the
issue of culture and strategy
when you took over at mozilla for
example
well i didn't take over in mozilla um i
joined mozilla so mozilla had this long
long history of being a startup an open
source
project that had been going for a long
time for
eight years or something like that by
the time i i joined and then he had just
launched firefox and just started to be
successful
and i joined in a role that wasn't a
particular leadership role i
i was um on the executive team but i
didn't have a i didn't have much of a
team
i um i wasn't the ceo and in fact
when i joined like there were a lot of
things that i said that were
they were wrong and really provoked a
lot of antibodies uh
you know i started saying things that
didn't quite match the ethos or the
mission or the
other culture of the place and very
quickly people explained to me why that
was
you know um apostate and horrible that i
could think that stuff it's like holy
smokes like who is this guy is a suit
and so i had to figure out how to how to
number one understand the organization
understand the cultural norm some of it
was written and some of it and a lot of
it wasn't like any organization
and then but a lot of it's just like you
have to walk around and talk to people
and understand why they're there and
what what they're doing
and over times i started started to
invest in
my understanding of culture and invest
in my contributions to the culture
then i got enough of you know a
so-called bank account of credibility so
that i could
start to say well i think that if we we
could be stronger if we did this or that
and i eventually became the ceo um but
that was kind of an outgrowth of
leadership it was it wasn't it was a
consequence
more than it was um more than wasn't
triggered to be honest with you so
by the time that i was became ceo
mitchell and i had been running the
organization together for
for quite some time um but when i got
there it was about 12
employees and quickly grew to maybe 50
that first year
in 2005 when firefox was growing and by
the time i left there's about
four or 500 employees but
um the mozilla always understood its
mission
and understanding your missions are a
huge step towards understanding how to
build culture because
you've got mission and you've got
operating principles and values about
how you
go attack the mission and then once you
start to
start to if you can understand mission
super clearly mozilla's mission is just
to make sure that the internet
is strong and belongs to everyone not
just big companies
they say oh well that mission implies
these values which are
people have to understand what we're
doing so there must be transparency
people need to
people should be able to contribute no
matter where they live in the world that
means we must be
multicultural and multi-multilingual um
you know so there's all these values
and once you understand these values
that very very clearly starts to say
well
if we if it has to be multi-uh lingual
multicultural multi-time zone
that means we have to have um video
that's available to for all
all hands all the time and this was in
2005 and that was a little bit hard to
do
now you can obviously do it um you know
it meant that
you know we had to have uh you know cl
clear systems for how you interact in
multiple languages for example
uh meant that for bohr me because we
believed in transparency is a value
because only with information can you
participate
um you know when you had board meetings
i would spend time and go through the
board deck
for hours for anybody who wanted to
understand it and wanted to see it and
so
i think that understanding mission and
um
mission leads to values values leads to
cultural
and the specifics of the mechanics um
and then there's just day-to-day stuff
so you know i put
i think i've told you before like uh as
we grew
people like any organization people
start to feel alienated from the
organization
and alienate from leadership as you
start to get levels in between
uh individuals and leadership and so
you know one of the things i did when we
moved to new office a new bigger kind of
a little bit alienating office i stuck
my desk and i had my stand-up desk that
i kind of stuck in the middle of a
hallway
so that as people people walked in
like i was i was standing up and working
and you couldn't help but make contact
i'd make eye contact with me if you make
eye contact with somebody you're
pretty likely to say hi because it's
awkward if you don't and
and so suddenly now you're everybody's
talking to the ceo in ways that maybe
you wouldn't
if the ceo is off in a corner in the
office and so just little things that
um that was a that was a value of
openness and transparency and connection
and any questions okay little things
like that tend to reinforce the values
all the way up
uh to your value stack and then all the
way up to mission after that
lovely example lovely example now let me
take you to let me take you to your vc
incarnation at greylock
i'm sure you must have listened to lots
of pitches from entrepreneurial teams
and as you listen to them you sort of
size up
does their strategy make sense but i
imagine you pay
you paid attention to their culture too
so
how did you address pictures where the
strategy was great but the culture was
if you will somewhat suspect what did
you guys do what did you personally
do did you choose not yet
um yeah i made a lot of mistakes on i
made
a lot of decisions that would have
passed up good investments um for
companies that i thought were
culturally um problematic um
and sometimes that means that the values
of the company don't align with values
that i care about sometimes it means
that
the founder doesn't totally understand
how to build
um connection and culture in their
company
but i would say that i think it's very
like i think it's very very hard to
understand any culture from the outside
i think full stop i think it's hard it's
a different kind of hard to understand
from the inside
but i think that just like understanding
it's impossible to understand anybody
else's relationship
fully i think that for investors on the
outside
you can understand what the founder is
like and you can in
in molly graham who um
you know was uh built up articulated a
bunch of facebook's early culture for
example and then quips after that
you know she likes to say that you know
80 of your culture comes from your
founders
from the things that they care about the
things that they do and partly it's
because they're they're such
strong carriers of culture and
such strong role models and partly
because they just set up all the all the
mechanisms and all the
all the um all the routines um and so
just a lot of it comes to the founder
and so as an investor
well i think i i thought it was very
hard i mean
you have to understand that as soon as
you go in and look at a company quote
look at a company
to visit an office when back when we
could visit offices
um you know to assume that you can
understand anything about what's really
happening by
observing what's happening in physical
space is i think a little ridiculous
and so all you can really do is
understand you can talk to founders
understand why they made the decisions
they made why how they think about
decisions that are in the future and
just spend a lot of time with them
thinking about that
and then you can sometimes understand
the the way that other people on their
team
talk about that stuff and think about
that stuff and the way that they think
about hiring other members of the team
but i think that believing you
understand the culture because you're
because of as you invest i think is
it i think it's quite hard wonderful
wonderful as i i of course have a number
of questions to ask of you
but uh the participants in our webinar
tour uh you know sharing a number of
questions i thought i'd
channel a couple of them so let me begin
with the very first one
how do you manage a situation asks one
of our viewers
when you know there is actually a big
change
uh a situation or a crisis where the
startup could be scaled
due to an unforeseen event like covet
yeah there's not a lot of unseen events
like covet covet is a little bit
uh one of a kind um so
uh let me answer this question in two
ways so basically it's like what do you
do
when something happens it's unforeseen
like like covet and so i would say
there's two categories of things there
are things that are
like unforeseen things that are kind of
workable and there's unforeseen things
that are a little bit like
global pandemic which is i think a
completely
unprecedented thing like for at least in
our work style
let me take the unprecedented stuff
first then we'll come back to the like
more normal um unforeseen things uh what
i would say with covid
is we are all figuring it out together
as we go
and i'm on the boards of eight companies
i guess
and i talk to the leaders of these
companies uh
you know at least every week about how
they're doing it and they're all doing
it
they're all dealing with covent
differently um the companies that
had gotten to some scale and some
momentum
before coven i think are doing the best
the companies that were kind of
wandering around trying to figure out
how to build how to find
customers and how to find right product
market fit that's the most dangerous so
it's at some level
the companies that are earliest are the
ones that are going off and building
product they don't really need to talk
to anybody
like being remote is fine the companies
that are are at scale and have had
customer momentum already are doing fine
it's the ones that are in the middle
that are looking for product market fit
that are in the really most challenging
position
but everybody's situation is different
and um
what i'm i'm learning from the ceos that
i interact with
uh every day as we talk through this
stuff um
figma for example where i'm on the board
dylan the ceo said well we don't
what he realized is that their
management team was talking a lot about
when should we go back to the office
and so they spent a lot of time on
management teams like well should we go
back should we
tell people we're going to go back at
the end of the year or next year or when
should we say that
and what they realized is that they
didn't really have the right language to
talk about this because there's not
it's not clear that there's a back to go
to
and what was clear that became clear to
dylan is that
everybody's grieving the loss of what we
had before
and there were all sorts of different
assumptions about what
next would look like and so they just
did a survey let's say they said let's
ask people
how they're feeling what they're
thinking about what they would do
given choices and let's not assume that
there's
there's going back to what it was like
ever let's think about what we wanted to
be
like in the future um and construct it
going that direction so let's get data
let's think about our back to our values
what do we care about how do we build it
and then let's think about what that
makes sense what makes sense in the
future and so they and then they
they were open about it and they said
well here's what we got here's what
we're thinking about
we'll give you clarity and one of the
other things became clear is that the
people that needed the most clarity
around covid for example were parents
because parents have kids in school um
and school in the united states is very
uncertain
right now like uh you know my
eight-year-old is uh in the room next
door
and so he he'll burst in here at any
moment during our podcast but um
we'll see but every appearance is like
is going through that stuff and so
you know figma said well we'll give you
clarity you don't have to come back to
the office until june
after that here are what we're hearing
about the culture we want to build
and we're going to construct between now
and then we'll construct what the
what the new the new reality is like the
same
yeah i'm hearing the same types of
things from code for america where i'm
on the board it's a non-profit
um you know it's um
i also what i'm also finding is that in
a in a in a situation situation like
this it's lasting for so long
people are it's taken some people a
little while to
settle into the to the understanding
this is going to be
you know a year and so once and so it
takes people
a little while to internalize that this
is the situation over time
and i think that most companies have
gone through this mania
where they said man this is incredible
it's working great
like how great is zoom and there's no
commute
and then you start to realize all the
things that you lost
and and need to reinvest in around
connection and building up the company
that kind of thing
this is kind of a long one way of saying
everybody's sorting this out together
um then there are no models and i do
really
value companies like stripe and coinbase
and figma that are doing this in the
open and even google lately
who said this is our plan it's subject
to change but here's why we're doing it
so that you can we can have this
discussion and talk about it and i think
that the best companies will bring
employees in together so here's a
wonderful question from
one of our viewers you know is culture
face to face can you build culture when
work is remote
and if so how do you do that do you have
any stories any examples is the question
yeah i think that um
so i don't think culture is face to face
i think that
we build cultures uh in any way humans
can
can communicate we build culture what i
think is harder is that
um the percentage of the
the way the ways that things get done
that people can't see
is much higher when you're having a
remote a remote culture potentially much
higher when you have a remote culture
than when you don't
so if you're in the office and you see
leadership make decisions and they
go to meetings they talk right on
whiteboards they have all hands whatever
you can see a lot of the things that
people they might not be formal decision
making
and so when you've got uh remote
cultures
the most aggressive ones like gumroad
for example run by sahel lavinjia
they write down everything and so their
their move to remote
like they have more culture that's
explicit than most companies that are in
person
so they don't rely on the in-person as a
crutch
and so as a result like covet and remote
has been
fine for them um what i found is that
the um that moving to
zoom calls and so i think a lot of
people now are you know your
wall-to-wall zoom and
it's a little bit more transactional
than your typical office environment and
so your office environment
you go in and you waste a lot of time
you'd waste a lot of time
you'd have lunch with people or you chat
with them in the kitchen or
you'd have a lot of down time where you
maybe talked about things that weren't
you know maybe quite important enough to
talk about in the meeting
um and i think that with zoom calls you
tend to say well the purpose of meeting
is x
let's talk about x once we're finished
with x
let's all get off the call and so you're
not
uh you're not doing these uh
serendipitous interactions and so you
tend to be
a little more um uh focused on your
particular group and your particular
project
in the in the connectivity with other
groups outside serendipitous
connectivities
is diminishing and so what i find
what i hear all the companies i'm
interacting with is they're all looking
for
how do we build spaces and time
to to recapture some of that
serendipitous investment
um and that's i think going to be the
key so i would say that the companies
are working best for the ones that
invested
in culture and helping people understand
culture before
we move to this remote world and we've
kind of been drawing down on that bank
account
since shelter in place started and that
you have to reinvest in it now there's
other cultures that have
like i said with gumroad for example or
wordpress that's run but it's been run
remotely by matt mullenwig forever
that have done really well in this way
and they've built these patterns and
routines
for how to connect in mozilla we were
hybrid the whole time we had an office
in mountain view we had offices around
the world
and so we coped by just having a lot of
people on
synchronous communication irc and slack
we had a lot of people
um on calls all the time
and then we just made sure that
everybody understood that they could
travel to see people face to face
anytime they wanted which obviously is
not the situation is today
but you find ways to invest
that's actually very helpful in the
meantime our mischievous colleague bob
sutton has come up with a question
and the question is how do you know when
your culture is being violated and what
do you do
yeah um well violated that's an
interesting word so
if to the extent that you can build
i mean think back to the value stack so
think back to mission
values operating principles and how they
how they should align
and so what you're trying to do is
create situations where
whether or not a founder or leader is in
the room everybody kind of knows what
the right thing to do is
and so when you talk about culture
violations that will tend to be
oh well that person made a decision
without it wasn't data based
or they made that person made a decision
that wasn't in the interests of
customers or that person made a decision
and didn't tell anybody so they weren't
transparent enough
and if you built your culture and if
you've communicated the way things
happen in the right ways if you've built
that
in itself and reinforced enough and told
that story enough then everybody will
say well that's not the way we do things
here
and when you say that's not the way we
do things here sometimes that means
you're making me uncomfortable and so
you need to kind of disentangle
discomfort from genuine genuine
violation
but but that's that's okay and then and
then i think that
what i always try to do is model
behavior
in front of other people around what to
do
when something doesn't feel like it's in
aligned culturally so
uh i think i've talked to you before
about at mozilla as we started growing
we had 40 or 50 percent
50 people in organization we started
having layers of management
i started having meetings with not just
my direct reports but
their reports and so what i was looking
for was
i was always very honest with my vice
presidents
when i they said something i said well
that doesn't sound right or that sounds
problematic well let's fix that
and i was trying to i wanted other
people to see me interact with vps in
ways that was specific
and corrective but not judgmental
and so you're trying to find ways to
model that behavior so that everybody
else can say well that doesn't sound
right to me
let's get to the root of it without
being personalized for example
that's very helpful there are a number
of other questions that are being asked
as well
john one sort of question is when does
culture become a hindrance and how do
you know that
yeah well look i think culture's always
uh
always cuts both ways i think that
for startups mostly and really i really
mean is challenger challenger companies
for challenger companies have to be
spiky in ways that
incumbents don't so incumbents they
they draw their strength and their huge
distribution and from
their um the way that they do things is
sort of the status quo
and challengers uh like netflix was
a while ago you know might be online
only versus blockbuster
challengers need to be um defined
and specific and spiky and so most
cultures say
and so you know netflix was famous for a
long time
saying look if we here's our culture and
they try to say they put in a deck they
said here's the way we operate
and if you're here and you don't think
that that describes you
like take a layout package and we'll pay
you to we'll pay you to quit
and definitely don't apply here if this
doesn't sound like you and so they were
trying to figure out how to help people
self-select
inner self-select out because they felt
like the culture made them
uh distinctively shaped
to compete in the market now once you
get big um
so i think your culture can pull you off
any time like if your culture is not
aligned
with your strategic goals you're closer
to not in line with your tactics
you can you can kind of last for a
little bit with that misalignment which
kind of last
can't last forever and so especially as
you start to get big
you start to try to do more things you
start to
hire more types of people it tends to be
harder
to maintain the spikiness of your
culture
but i think that you also just have to
understand fitness for purpose and
like i said it's always best to say
here's our mission
here are the goals we're trying to do
now hear how the values attach to the
goals
and trying to reinforce which which uh
cultural norms make sense any given time
it's very helpful in the meantime
just a quick note to our participants
and listeners in this webinar
please continue to keep the flow of
questions
it's a gift to us we very much value it
so one other question from the list
given by colleagues there and that is
what are the three traits required to
build the culture
the three traits required to scale a
culture is there a difference
oh uh that's interesting three traits
well the first thing is i just think
intentionality so being able to
articulate
what you're trying to do like i said if
you don't if you don't build it
intentionally it'll tend to build you
and so you'll tend to be reactive not
not active so the first thing is
understanding what you're doing
and and being intentional about it the
second thing is i think you have to be
very and i guess the second two i think
you have to be very disciplined
about communication so
you know molly we talked about molly
graham earlier um
who started to define the company
culture at facebook in the early
days after being at google and she just
wanted to talk about what's the story
like what does hack mean you know
facebook talked about
move fast and break things which um i
think has since been
a little bit uh villainized but at the
time
you know when they were startup it meant
do whatever it takes to keep the service
running
and then as a over time that that sort
of
that started changing and morphing into
like well try things but don't
but don't kill the service for our users
that kind of thing
the um so i think that so being
disciplined
being and being communicative and i
think that
for me it's not so much talking about
things in culture
but is saying here's how we make
decisions we make decisions based on
data or we make decisions based on what
customers want or we make decisions
based on what employees
have been noodling on and what the you
know what the market says
and so just being clear and being
disciplined and always being
willing to go back and say well here's
why we're doing the thing we're doing
hmm so which brings me to another
question that was also listed in
uh some way or shape and that is when
you actually
make culture explicit should you
emphasize the good things what is sacred
or should you emphasize the things
people should never do
the stuff that is taboo which one is
kind of more important
yeah um for me
uh you know maybe because i'm an
engineer i've always found it easier and
more
more natural to say well that's the
stuff we don't do let's fix those
let's fix problems because i'm an
engineer by background
i think it's often more uh
i think it gives you more value to
highlight the things that are
that are sacred and things that are
excellent about culture
it will tend to reinforce good behaviors
as opposed to
um i think that sorry i think that you
need to reinforce good behaviors more
than you need to say
that's a bad behavior i think people
will tend to over rotate on things that
are bad
and under notice praise uh and so
what what i had to learn over time is to
say that's a really good example of why
we do how we do things the right way
as opposed you know the ceo calling out
a behavior that wasn't good for a
customer wasn't good for an employee you
do that once
everybody in the world notices it saying
way to go great job of the customer uh
people will tend to dismiss that and so
i think you have to do that probably ten
times
or a hundred times every time you say
well this is this is problematic
but i do think there are cultures that
don't say this is problematic enough and
then
it gets it gets out of control very
quickly to the extent you don't correct
right so one related question
it's a it's a big meaty topic
and that is one of our viewers says hey
in this environment diversity and
inclusion have become salient
what do you recommend that a company do
to improve its track record on the
diversity front
especially when it has enabled
discrimination in the past
that's the question
yeah well we have a lot of work to do um
obviously it's hugely important every
company
uh that's that i'm interacting with uh
cares about it uh like everything else i
think the first thing you want to
be able to articulate as a company is
why you care
so i think that being able to say we
care about diversity because
or we care about inclusion because and
then finishing that sentence is huge
so sometimes people say well because
it's the right thing to do
and i think that's 100 valid and fair
other people say we want we care about
diversity inclusion because
it helps us serve our customers better
because it reflects our customer base
better
because it makes me happier to go to
work
here it's a because it makes stronger
products because it makes stronger play
base
but i think that being able to think
through both
why you think it makes you better and
what aspirationally
you're doing it for that will give you
um
a framework for how to think about it
and talk about it over time i think
without that without the because
i think you're just trying to get a
thing that i think will
it will be hard to figure out the ways
to do it authentically
um as for how to fix diversity like in
inclusion
you know one of the companies i work
with i mentioned called quip where brett
taylor who's now the president of
salesforce
uh started in molly molly worked for um
they were about 50 women in the in the
engineering team and you say well how
did you do that
and what they said is well we hired half
women it wasn't that hard we just did it
and so there's something about
complaining and ringing your hands about
diversity so hard and pipeline so hard
and there's something else that said
well we're not going to
do it unless we can hire diverse
diversity
now hiring diversity is only the first
part you've got to make sure that
you build support and structures for
them to have voice
and if you might have one type of
diversity but not other types of
diversity but this all
all works back to you like why are you
doing it and
what's the main goal so
um yeah and so i think that you have to
just be continually
looking for what bias exists in
organization
where is there unintentional bias where
is their
invisible bias how do we surface it how
do we create structures for people
who to have voices who have not had
voices historically
and that's i think constant you know we
you know we'll make progress
on racial diversity or gender diversity
and we need to make progress
elsewhere and so we just it's a it's a
constant i think it's a
it ends up being a value of the company
and you like the other values you will
you'll say this is a value and then the
way you operate and the way you work
will either reinforce or not again
that's very helpful one question is
do you have a taxonomy of cultures in
mind
you know are there different types of
cultures and if so
what's the taxonomy you lean on is the
question
that is an interesting and complicated
question i mean the companies that we
all know the best uh you know the
companies that are giants around here
now you think about apple or google
and if you are around silicon valley
long enough you'll tend to you'll tend
to have a short hand for oh that
person's kind of amazony or that
person's kind of aptly or that's kind of
googly
er and the
um i don't think i have a taxonomy
except to say that
you know google is uh very collegial
in nature they tend to have very open
open culture they tend to
say here's the information go look at it
make your own decisions be smart
apple tends to be tends to kind of break
everything you read and
management uh and you've heard of the
gsp
and they didn't say we're very siloed
we're not gonna have a lot of mobility
between jobs you're gonna just go do
your job and not
not ask a lot of questions not try to
try anything outside of your job
so they tend to be very siloed very um
information uh um securing
that kind of thing you know you've got
older cultures like microsoft that tend
to be a little bit more traditional in
the way that they think about
roles um and then more modern cultures
like stripe
who tends to be very very engineering
based or
you know ebay who's very product
management based but
these things uh they all kind of start
from the seed of their founders and they
kind of
grow over time and they kind of develop
certain
certain ways of doing you know certain
ways of being and it's
i don't i don't think i have a really
good taxonomy except for organizations
that tend to
well i mean you know maybe the best
taxonomy would be one that you've talked
about you and bob have talked about in
your books which is like how do you
scale in a buddhist way or do you scale
in a catholic way
um so you talk about how do you how do
you grow and in catholicism obviously
the analogy is that catholic
organizations they are like
the catholic church which is the source
of truth is the pope in rome
and everything comes from that and apple
is clearly the
most catholic of organizations in in the
world it certainly was under steve jobs
with tim it's a little less catholic
but buddhist scaling would be let's
teach people how to think let's make
sure they understand our operating
principles
and then let's let them go out and and
and work
and google tends to be a little bit more
buddhist uh in that way and so
you know that that's a reasonable
taxonomy for me that's how i would think
about it as i was looking for a place to
join i
i like buddha's organizations more than
like catholic organizations even though
at two trillion dollars apple's a pretty
good example of a catholic organization
a pretty good catholic organization
yeah so there are a number of other
questions
that are being uh asked as well
uh john i'm going to sort of select and
uh
tell them one interesting question is
when there is a crisis
when there is pressure how do you calm
employees down
um sure so sometimes you don't want them
to calm down sometimes you want them to
realize it's a crisis
um you know i think uh
but often you want them to be in their
rational head space and think about what
to do
and almost always that has to do with if
you're intentional about
i mean i hate to to reiterate but if you
if you're intentional about
mission values operating principles you
can just go back and say
yes this is a problem because it's
misaligned with our values or because
it's
misaligned our operating principles or
because it misaligns the mission you can
start to articulate
where the gap is and say and
so once we know where the gap is we can
say well we should fix it because
there's a there's a gap or we should
change our values because
the reality is the reality is more
correct than what we thought our values
were
our articulated values were or this is
wrong and it doesn't match
and so we're gonna we're gonna change
the way we behave so that it comes back
into alignment with our values so i
think that
the more that you have been explicit and
intentional about these things over time
the easier it is to calm things down
the part where you get uh in trouble
is when you have not been explicit about
these things and you haven't shared
these things and something happens
and then suddenly you need to explain
explain
what to do and you don't have a history
of blogging second i think about
there were there were some venture firms
that got
uh pulled into things that
uh sort of she said um
uh me too type stuff um you know maybe
10 years ago
and i remember one of the one of the
partners
had a blog post like here's why it's
totally not true and we were doing the
right thing
and if you look back it's the first time
he had blogged in
10 years and so there was just no
credibility and no framework to
understand
how he was thinking and why this wasn't
just
being defensive whereas if he had been
sharing all along you'd have said oh
this lines up with all the other things
that
that he said all along and here's why
this kind of follows as a consequence
um but you know as a one-off it was not
very not particularly credible
lovely so there are a number of
questions again that are coming up we're
very grateful
it's 10 42 i'm also keeping track of
time
uh because my boss robin today will tell
me hey
we're getting close to 11 i want to make
sure i'm mindful
at this stage i thought it would be
interesting for all
in the webinar or conversation
to listen to a young stanford student
this young stanford student wanted to be
a scientist first and now after coming
to stanford wants to be an entrepreneur
uh she's an amazing young woman i want
to welcome olivia
halsey olivia welcome please join us
and i know that you have a couple of
questions welcome to the conversation
olivia
so why don't you fire away a couple of
questions you're thinking of becoming an
entrepreneur
yeah right yes yes
i um would love to become an
entrepreneur one day and i really it's
been such a privilege to listen to you
both today
and i mean i'm thinking about becoming
an entrepreneur
i think a lot about how to establish
culture
and then preserve that culture as you
scale so i wanted to know
what are some key constructs and
processes
that engender and safeguard equity
within an organization and then how do
you
intentionally strengthen these as a
founder or a manager within an
organization
yeah your questions um so thanks thanks
levi the
question is about how do you uh
safeguard equity is that
that's that the core of your question
yes
yeah yeah it's um it's an interesting
question so i think that
the first thing you have to do is you
have to model so you have to model
patients you have to model
um that when
questions arise when comments arise that
you value the
the the line of questioning and thoughts
from the from the the questioner
themselves so
i think that one of the things that
founders uh and leaders often forget is
that
the world doesn't a lot of founders in
in leaders like forget that most people
don't
see all the things that are happening
and can't see the whole the whole board
and so they can get they often get a
noise like well why don't you understand
this is what we're doing or why why do
you have that point of view it's like
why can't you just
like like it's really obvious and so it
has to come from a place of
um understanding that your point of view
is not
you can't see the same things that
everybody else can see and so
um and then the second thing i guess
would say
is you have to to the degree that you
can
you have to not react in ways that are
ever seen very
frustrated with people and so i i really
struggled with this especially the first
time i was a ceo
that when i f i was always working on
the next set of problems
and when people ask me like why did you
do this
thing in a dumb way ceo i got
i could get short and a lot of founders
are like this because they're always
trying to think about the next thing
and so if i was short that shut people
down for
you know sometimes forever sometimes
they would never ever turn back on
because the ceo was short with them
and so i started learning how to
just be patient how to let people finish
the question how to ask more questions
about why they were asking
and then to share share those as much
information as i could
um and when i made mistakes that was i
still makes mistakes about being short
and um from time to time always to go
back to them and say
uh and try to try to address it as
quickly as you can
and say hey tell me more about what you
want to understand tell me more about
how you how you want to
how you want to engage and i'll share
whatever i can with you
and so i got some of that writing some
of that wrong but i think you always
have to
model um patience model listening
model engagement um you know at figma
where dylan
uh field as a ceo you know he um
their values were you know uh create
you know celebrate diversity create
inclusion um
have fun and they they start they start
every talk with those same
every every presentation to the company
they start by putting up the same values
every time
it seems like a gimmick for a little
while but then you play forward to
where you know that two-thirds of the
people had female were here
a year ago and you start to see it's
like oh
that's what we did we say that but it's
not just a slogan
here's how it here's how it gets
reflected by the q and a period is
is at least as long as the meeting
itself was so
you start to realize all the ways that
it reinforces um
but it's it's like all this stuff is
just continuous you just have to keep
working at it
and in addition yeah
just just building off of what you just
said i think
what i found from my very limited work
experience
um that culture can sometimes be
different
at different levels within an
organization and i think
what separates work experiences is when
a culture is uniform and strong at
every level in an organization and so i
was wondering
from your perspective what levers you
have found
um you know or efforts
you can perform and enforce within an
organization to ensure that a culture is
uniform
and strong and upheld by every employee
in an organization
yeah that's an awesome question i think
that um
the first the first thing the first part
is like just remembering just
remembering that that's true
and that somebody coming out of college
will perceive the culture in a way
that's completely different than
a vice president um who's you know in
their 40s
um and but the second thing i think for
leadership in particular would be
to be curious about people and and so
i mean this is we don't talk about
hewlett-packard very much anymore but
but they used to talk about um mbwa
which was management by walking around
and so those guys even as hewlett even
as hp was growing and hp used to be an
incredible company like
much different than it is today i mean
you see like the smartest most tenant
like the google of you know 50 years ago
maybe
and you know you'd be working on
something at your workbench and then
suddenly that one of the founders would
come just sit down and say hey tell me
what you're working on
and um because they were probably
because they were just nerds they were
curious
uh they wanted to know um but partly
it's like
it what the the the what they're
communicating is that
the work that individuals are doing
that's the work of the company not the
management of the company per se
and so like partly it's just like you
look for ways to blow up
the divisions at every level and to mix
people up and i think that's actually
one of the
like slight one of the real challenges
of this remote culture we're building
is that you gotta find ways to intermix
i think it's really easy just to
interact with people on your team or at
the same level
and so we've got to find ways to have
cross-cutting um
conversations uh as much as we can
but i think i think that's a really good
one i think the other thing is like i
i would pretty routinely talk to people
about you know who are
uh you know three years out of school
and a staff engineer and they said well
i want to be a
vice president of engineering and we
were pretty routinely talked about
let's talk about what i expect out of
vice presidents of engineering
that this is the set of things that i
expected to be able to demonstrate and
let's talk about what you can
demonstrate now
and see if we can be explicit about the
gap and so if you can be explicit about
the gap then you can start to start to
climb up in that way
and so it's having conversations that
are real and specific
um but don't feel overly judgmental with
anybody at any level i think is is part
of the key too
i'm keeping track of time we have
another eight minutes
uh and there are a couple more questions
so if you don't mind olivia i'm going to
interleave one of them
and this is a very personal question
john this is again from
um bob and bob asks what did you learn
about culture as a ceo
what did you learn about culture as a
venture capital
a partner and investor and is there a
difference and if so what
yeah uh well um
by and large i mean cultures are defined
by the people who are there not by the
people who are investors and so
vcs i think you know you're along for
the ride a little bit and you can
affect the way that people ask questions
you can affect the way that leaders lead
a little bit but
like their effect on the culture i think
is somewhat minimal um
you know this this other question from
bob like
the other half of his question the
statement after his question was that he
was there and i was pretty impatient
which is true
um
yeah yeah i mean what i learned about my
first my first gig was just my first ceo
job is that
uh i was in a big rush to do things all
the time
and the more that i acted like that the
less able i was to lead
and so the more that i want the more
that i was able to create
other what i really wanted is other
people to be in a rush and pull me
rather than me to be in a rush and pull
them and so what i wanted to build is
urgency and alignment
more than i wanted to say come on come
on come on let's go
um and so i mean that's that's it mostly
is this i learned
in my my second my second ceo job i was
more
patient i think i listened more and i
was looking to
create more leaders and i was looking to
create more leaders
uh and lead less myself i think it's
what i that's the way i would say it
wonderful olivia you have the floor do
you have another
question for joan
yes yes um thank you so much i
also i mean selfishly i think
we all would love to learn about how in
your career if you think any efforts
that
you did particularly stand out as being
especially effective
in shifting a culture in a new direction
because i think we've spoken a lot about
how to establish a culture
but is there a way to really you know
move a culture
into a new more positive place and
allowing it to develop
yeah i mean i don't what i would say is
i don't have that much experience but
we of moving cultures i think that uh i
think that once you have values and
cultures
in a certain direction it's hard to it's
hard to move them
um culture tends to be sticky in a way
that marketing messages are sticky
they tend to be ingrained values and in
ways of doing things
i do think that very often people pay
attention to who you promote
and who you hire and so i think that
very visible
uh uh celebrations of people in that way
are huge
i think that to the degree that you um
yeah so i think that that's part of it
so i think that who you hire who you
promote who you
who you talk about who you value who you
amplify
that's the that's about the best you can
do i think that people
just listening to you talk about this is
the important thing to do culturally
this is why we are
why we are who we are it doesn't have
much as much
impact by a long stretch as saying
people saying oh
i value i i believe that this is the way
we are because this person
i believe in this person because these
people are all lined up
it's a pretty squishy answer i'm sorry
so using reward systems is a very
powerful lever
in a sense to change culture changing
jobs is another way to change culture
now i'm very mindful of time so i want
to sort of close on one
big issue uh john and
you know and this is that when people
comp you know the arc of course is
to go from startup to scale when you're
a startup you're a small team with big
people
but when you're a scale-up the danger is
you become a large company with a lot of
small
people how do you as the ceo
honey is the founder what do you do to
culture to to to offset that
it's a cousin of uh olivia's question as
well as a number of questions on our
list
yeah again i would so to go to bring us
all the way back to the beginning i'd
say
understand what kind of culture you are
and understand why you're doing the
things you're doing so
i think that um inside
google for example they've created as
many leadership jobs as possible
so you know obviously sundar is the ceo
of alphabet but he was ceo of google
before that and then
working for him is susan wojcicki who's
the ceo of youtube and
there's a ceo of waymo and a ceo of
google x and so there
are these leadership positions where
people have the ability
to run the organizations that that they
have responsibility for
um in by contrast like apple would be
say look here you're in the marketing
silo or you're in the engineering silo
or you're in the
services silo and your job is to be
as you own everything across the whole
company in this particular way
but it's all about how do you create
ownership how do you create agency how
do you create um as much space for
people to
make decisions and make mistakes uh of
the on their own
and accountability um and so i i mean
i'd say that's i mean
that's the that's the start and the
finish that you you have mission
goals values and enough space for
leaders to
be genuine leaders and not just work for
somebody else but work with you
right that's wonderful and it's
wonderful
i'm very mindful we're getting to the
close of our webinar
yeah i'm just going to make one or two
closing observations
i just want to express my gratitude to
john
for taking the time to share his
reflections and his wisdom
and i want to express my deep
appreciation to all of our listeners
for so generously giving us the
questions
as you can see we combined the questions
some of them were also asked by olivia
as well thank you olivia
for doing that uh as you walk away from
this webinar
you might want to keep in mind a couple
of things i think
and that is and i think john put this
beautifully which is
you build culture culture builds you so
in other words
if you're going to go from start up to
scale up make sure your culture scales
your people too
makes them bigger than they are and this
is the message
that john was actually offering
the other sort of important uh takeaway
for
all of you is in
and i i really like the emphasis that
john placed on the way we do things and
actions
and indeed in the course that john sujay
and i
teach on startup to scale up we sort of
emphasize this in
detail where we talk about caring
sharing and daring being the muscles
that are necessary
to propel you from startup to scale
on a personal note i want to steal a
line from my wonderful colleague
friend and collaborator bob sutton
and that is uh you know bob always says
as a leader the most important thing is
when you meet
somebody they should walk away with
positive energy
that's absolutely true that is the
single biggest predictor of whether
you're able to engage people and
mobilize people
if you drain energy from other people
it's not going to do very much
to that i'd you know tack on one more
thing and this is something
john's kind of been emphasizing and that
is great leaders also ask
helpful questions so if you really want
to measure yourself
as a builder of culture when you lead a
meeting
when you bring a team together ask
yourself
how many helpful questions did i ask
other people
because i want to turn as many lights on
in the house
versus how many statements i made
either of my opinion or my experience
meaning
statements like in my experience in my
opinion
and once you track that measure that's
actually going to give you
a very good insight into you and indeed
the company
so look at that metric number of helpful
questions
divided by the number of statements of
opinion or expertise and if you keep in
mind both of those things
i think you'll actually be if you will
not just a builder of culture
not just a bearer of culture you'll
actually be a propagator of cultures
so thank you all for your time thank you
and let's give a warm round of applause
to john as well
so please join me in giving an
electronic round of applause this time
nice to see you guys yeah over to you
robin
thank you so much thank you thank you
john thank you olivia
for this valuable conversation everyone
in the audience i know
please let me echo that all your
valuable questions and participation
really make
this time together so special so thank
you so much
if you enjoyed the conversation you're
interested in learning more
um you should check out our new course
x90242
building company culture which is linked
in your dashboard
and i want to remind you that today's
session was recorded and a link will be
made available to you within a week so
you can review it if you'd like and have
it
thank you everyone signing off from
california
and stay safe please thank you
you